[Music]
alright let's shift a little bit to some
specific issues cuz I think we've done a
nice little broad okay job to start here
you mentioned to me briefly something
about daca that I thought was really
interesting how the black community is
sort of split on this can yeah yeah you
know daca is on its surface isn't easy
it should be easy but what I've come
talking about the complexity of and the
nuances so increasingly our students on
HBCU campuses are raising they have real
beef with this is the way they described
it said one of the students put it in it
made me pause cuz I was like that's an
easy one you're not gonna send to a
million people home these kids were
brought here by their parents didn't
have a choice if I tell my daughter
we're going somewhere she's gone right
so that's what it is so I get it yeah
and then one of the young women put it
best she said you know think about the
she called it she said the irony of this
is that they're very the America is our
rallying around providing not only the
ability for these students to enroll in
school but oftentimes full scholarships
for these students the daca students Wow
she said and Here I am the legal
descendant of slaves we were forced to
come here and I have to figure out how
to pay for my education and so there's
this tension there's real tension and
they have to whisper it so I asked her I
said well why don't you just talk about
that in class and she said oh I would be
killed that you can't talk about that in
class she said but there's an
underground sort of conversation about
that doesn't seem that there if America
has enough money to provide additional
scholarship assistance to students then
shouldn't you take care of people like
us who were brought here our parents
were brought here and we truly are and
so I was like wow that's really it was a
really hadn't thought about it yeah made
me pause there's also a recent article I
think it's the Chicago times where a guy
wrote an editorial about Rahm Emanuel
wants to spend 1 or 2 million dollars on
providing IDs for undocumented
immigrants and the black aldermen had a
meltdown I mean literally is quoted all
over the papers saying this is a
and enough so enough we have Americans
here african-americans in Chicago who
need XY and Z and instead you want to go
spend a bit so there's a tension America
is that a really inflection point that's
just not black and white or conservative
and liberal there's tension now amongst
people of color yeah and it seems to me
that obviously that conversation is good
and it's nice to hear that a student
said something to you that made you
reevaluate because that shows you
practice what you preach obviously
that's right is there some is there
who's the leader right now if there I
know I know you probably get this one
all the time and I don't even like the
question in a certain way no but I can
but but who should black America
whatever that is it's so it's so stupid
talking about that stuff like who should
be in your opinion should the black
community be turning to to make some
sense of this because there's the usual
cast of characters right and we can name
all the ones that you don't like that
are on MSNBC today and I don't like them
either so let's just forget those guys
but others some people that we should be
looking at that and I don't even mean
just black America but no for people
that really care that's very that's
right about freedom so you make the good
point I don't even know America
generally you know that we can identify
someone who is sane and rational and
logical and thoughtful but in the
african-american community you've nailed
it I we had a generation of leaders and
they were right for that era and what
was going on fast forward 20 30 years
I'm not sure and I've actually sat with
a group of my counterparts you know 40s
successful and said who's the leader
who's the voice what voice captures
what's happening in afternoon American
community about to be fair it's not
monolithic African of course you know
like any other that's why I don't write
that's why we don't like it yeah but it
was never monolithic but we had leaders
Martin Luther King was a leader although
you know he he wasn't from industry he
didn't you know so but still he
represented just he caught and captured
the voice of the community I have to
honestly say and it's something that
bothers me I don't know who that person
is and and I'm not so sure that if you
asked him like people none of them would
say I'm not sure who that leader is yeah
and it's so complex because do you
remember a couple years ago when Oprah
said the thing about how
what we just need these old racists to
die and issues referee
she was referencing some people's
grandmothers and grandfathers and I
remember thinking and I have no beef
with old but I remember hearing that and
thinking this is so dangerous it gets
back to what we were talking about
earlier about how you just live in your
times and all that like no one wants to
look at their grandparents who live grew
up in a different time thing I don't
wait till you just drop dead so you
can't vote anymore with the and it makes
me think huh you know I had as my
grandmother taught school 46 years in
Brown County Florida and I remembered
she said something to me now and I think
the world of my grandmother she's still
like 93 years old 94 just had a birthday
and I remembered going down to the
University of Miami and I came home and
I was said I think I've met someone and
it was she assumed it was a white woman
because I'm in a majority institution
you know Lily white University of Miami
and she said son I'd rather you bring a
man home Allan
now this is someone who I adore and I
think the world of her but I had to stop
and pause her stuck me I remember that
I'd rather you bring a man home than a
white woman and I had to realize that a
lot of folks hold these racial so that
things and they are products of their
era like right so when I see you know an
older 90 year old lady or old white guy
who has and harbors some racial animus I
wasn't around then I can't really put
that in context I'm not justifying it
I'm not saying it's right or wrong but
what I am saying to your earlier point
is I love my grandmother and if you
tried to attack my grandmother because
she espoused that worldview
I would attack you yeah because I look
at the totality of her contributions to
this country and her her racist
tendencies are one a product of the
error that she grew up in but they are
also a very very small part of the full
woman that I know yes and that's the key
part everyone wants to define everybody
said earlier you could figure out
something that you did when you were 18
but something that I did when I was 26
and go man
right exactly but that's that's the
point that we're just pieces that's
right of all of this easy to and that's
that's a problem we just want to
collapse on the one thing that someone
did that's by the way unpopular now what
do you think Martin Luther King would
would think about the identity politics
stuff it's I I would like to think and
by the way I say that because you read
so many versions of what Martin fought
I've heard people say he was a
Republican and I've heard people help
he's a womanizer he's of this you just
don't know yeah I think you can make
interesting argument sometimes that he
was a conservative and now he doesn't
want his children to be judged by the
color of their skin that actually sounds
a little more like a conservative idea
because that's not an identity politics
idea yeah a lot of his economic stuff
was bearing more towards socialism in a
way so I think you can argue both but I
think on balance I think he would I
believe that he would be looking he's
looking down saying you know no system
is perfect no set of rules is perfect
but this is a lot better people today
than it was what we inherited back then
mmm-hmm is far worse than what you have
today so why don't we look at the
progress that was made and figure out
how we build on it I'd like to think
that because this nature was one of
working together finding commonality and
peaceful protests
you know people now you know not
allowing people to talk when you
disagree with them literally shouting
them down
think about that era when Martin Luther
King we were the minority then we're
clearly I mean really in a literally
they they could have silenced him by
yelling and shouting him down and
somehow the country allowed that voice
to - and people embraced it because they
listened to it even people who were
probably not inclined to agree with him
you know for that at that time yeah but
by listening they said huh maybe he's
done to something and it really piqued
their heart it got to the heart and said
you know what I'm this is probably not
the right way to think about my fellow
Americans it was because they listened
but if you aren't even being if you
can't hear if you're unwilling to listen
Martin has to be
and right now yeah yeah that I was just
at the mind minute I was telling you I
was just in DC gone all these things and
that's what I felt I just felt things
have gotten so much better for everybody
it doesn't let me right there isn't
racism it doesn't mean some people don't
like gay people or any of those things
but we are laws basically are fair yes
and it's like where else are they doing
it better that's right well are you
gonna move somewhere and I said the same
thing right after even after the Trump
election you know I remembered all those
folks if he's elected I'm leaving the
country
no she's still here right all of these
folks who Rosie named the group who all
thought they're gonna leave the country
I'm like you're not going anywhere
I don't want to go too far down the
Trump thing unless you want to go there
but no but do you think that whatever is
happening with him right now and as you
said as we're taping this today metaphor
it was was indicted by the FBI it sounds
like it's not even directly about the
Trump all right aim that it's about some
Ukraine stuff before but but we'll see
where all that plays out but as a
general rule what do you make of what's
happened because to me what I keep
trying to say is if you just let go of
the tweets for a minute you're like over
the media hysteria basically nothing bad
has happened basically well two things
first of all you'll leave on I know it's
hard to get rid of it no no you've only
had eight months up so yeah nothing bad
could really happen in eight months see
anyway this is a republic that has been
around for a very long time it's gonna
be around a long time after you so
that's the beginning the other thing is
it goes back to smiie do thing if you
are continually there's a barrage of
information that says everything this
person does is bad at some point you
believe it mm-hmm right and I think
that's a part of it he's trying to
figure it out
could he stay off the tweet a little bit
Twitter off yes yeah could he be a
little bit more presidential hell he
admitted it this weekend when he said
that but I'm about to say about Michael
Moore great well news alert President
Trump
several of those sorts of things have
not been president I'm glad you're
acknowledging yeah but no way he can't
though great because that's what got him
there that's what's got him there and
that that's what people forget it worked
and frankly as much as we talk about
he's not reflecting America yes he does
he
you know 43 million Americans voted for
him 46 for Hillary and people don't
factor the sin but three million Hillary
won the state of great state of
California or though by 3 million votes
people forget that so pull those that 3
million person spread was like here yeah
well for the record I in California
voted for Gary Johnson judge me however
you and all to another judge me however
you want but I suspect you would have
liked a lot of the ideas of Gary I did
in fact I did yeah but you know we knew
he wasn't gonna win
so that's a whole different conversation
but I but I I'm in California it didn't
matter which right that's like me in
Washington DC yeah oh yeah I know for
the Democratic candidate was gonna win
full-stop right yeah and again that gets
back to the issue this country is just
you're you're in one camp or the other
and it is when you think 46 and 43
million people
we're calling we really divided I mean I
just don't even know where the center is
anymore mm-hmm that's that's troubling
so to me the center basically is
somewhat economically conservative in
that yes you earn your money you should
keep it and I thought sorry always argue
that's the best way if you hate Trump
the best way to limit government is to
stop giving it so much money and power
it's right because sometimes you know
what you might get Bernie and he can use
a lot of power that you like but then
sometimes you're gonna get a guy you
don't like so let's just stop giving
them so much power but in a weird way
does this all show that our system is
working properly well that's you know
you mentioned earlier this is it's not a
perfect system but I don't there's no
other place in the world I'd rather be I
thank God every day when I wake up and
and so you know that I'm here and
because we could have all been born
somewhere else and this could have been
a really bad situation it's not a
perfect union but we're working towards
it and that's the optimism but it's only
if we have conversations like this the
two of us this doesn't appear on
mainstream television oh by the way
that's the thing that I gotta figure out
how to get you up and let me be your age
all right but we have to get out believe
you could do it I don't even know that I
want it but I believe they really could
because this voice is what's missing
you're either MSNBC or Fox News you're
Rachel or you're Hannity
and that by the way doesn't get us any
closer to fixing this because people
then divide out yeah that's what we've
got to do because rational people can I
think reasonable people can come to some
conclusions that this is good for all of
us
yeah you know relating this to sort of
where we started as you're saying this
I'm thinking you know there's something
interesting here if this identity
politics stuff wins the day and they
start taking down more monuments and we
start judging Thomas Jefferson and the
rest of the founders on the morals of
today it's not just that we'll remove
them but we'll actually all of their
good ideas all of their good ideas will
have to go away
they won't even if you like a lot of
those good ideas you mean like they
won't just magically keep some of the
ideas what you're gonna actually remove
all of those ideas and then what are we
left to it and it ain't pretty right and
it's not America that that's the reality
it's not America and that's something
that we've all got to come to grips with
is that this is not a good direction the
trajectory is all wrong I'm pleased to
say and all of us in the markets are
performing the financially you'll do
well but by the way if you don't have
any money you're not participating in
the markets anyway you're right right so
people like the two of us we're gonna do
fine yeah and our families and
significant others and stakeholders all
gonna do fine it's the rest of these
folks who being left out and they
unfortunately are buying into this
narrative that America is bad and
somehow the magic fix is to tax the
wealthy like oh where does that end like
oh and so is there is the appeal of that
just because it's sort of lazy thinking
you know you mean like it just doesn't
take much to be like I want what
somebody else has like it's kind of an
easy answer like I don't have somebody
all got they should give me some of that
like you don't have to think that hard
relax it to think harder to understand
why you shouldn't or don't deserve
someone else's money let's see I don't I
and why maybe but it's also equally lazy
to think if I were you know a
millionaire I wouldn't want to give more
of my money than someone else if I
earned it yeah even if I bought a
freaking lottery ticket you know just
basic take some person who's from a free
who's got limited resources and you say
to them you won the lottery tomorrow you
won two million dollars five million of
it goes to the federal government in
your state how does that make you bad
yes that's lazy I mean you don't think a
lot to say that's not a good result
right yeah
so I don't know why this is I don't know
that it's easy I think it's we have just
pounded into people's heads that taking
that the rich people are bad you're
vilified for going to work every day and
making some good decisions and some luck
and some God and some fate all of that
in the totality you're bad for having
done well and the media plays it
consistent they love it you believe it
yeah you believe it what do you think is
the right amount of government for us to
have as much as we need I know that's
not a great answer but I would literally
I'm sort of concerned not sort of I'm
very conservative in that respect I
don't think you can have no government
cuz then you have an R key we need so
you know what Mad Max right I don't want
that I mean if my house burns down I
want a police department to show if I
don't have to rely on my three neighbors
or the buckets to come so I've got a
fire department to show up so I think
government the infrastructure is
important of any society that will
endure I do think that we've gotten too
far though when you have just huge
bureaucracy and departments designed to
solve problems that frankly will solve
themselves amongst people yeah but we
become completely dependent on it is
there any way to scale it back that's
one of the questions I try to ask a lot
of my more libertarian guests yes like
it seems like this this thing has gotten
so big and when you factor it in with
you know handouts and all of this stuff
that if you were ever to take it back a
lot of people think will you just be
screwing over all the poor people all
that then I have some people who come on
and say no you just cut it tomorrow and
we see what happens will charities come
in will churches and synagogues and
mosques and all that will they pick up
the slack you know will if you cut the
funding to Planned Parenthood would
Barbra Streisand and Rosie and the rest
of them suddenly put some of their money
towards that I tend to think the answer
is yes me too
I do but how do you how do you get that
point across to people well they're not
going to do it unless force to do it so
I think so that's something to be said
for just
stop I mean what we saw Puerto Rico is a
classic example we're all forced you
know worried about what's happening in
Puerto Rico but this didn't start with a
hurricane mm-hmm Puerto Rico was a
disaster I mean when I'd read something
I was down there last year and I said 70
or so percent of the population work for
the government
like that is gotten out of control and
the only way you fix that you can't come
in and say hey guys 50 percent of you
all should give up your government jobs
right for us to get this right
no you just have to kind of just happen
you just have to and that's the frankly
that's the opportunity and I want to be
kill for you because I don't want I
didn't I'm not a Trump surrogate or
anything else but that's the opportunity
for someone like him I think we have
just elected our first independent
president I think it's the first time
that America has had someone who says
what they think forget of her bad butt
and who is prepared to be unpopular
because to make these sorts of decisions
you've got to be unpopular and okay with
that
so was that his best line during the
campaign when he said basically to the
black community he was like what do you
got to lose you think it was an actual
it ended up being a good line because it
sounded him off when I heard it and then
I've talked to a lot of people and they
kind of were like yeah all these
Democratic run cities Chicago Atlanta
Ferguson that's where the worst so it's
funny I remember deciding I know where I
was at that moment when that happen and
I was with a group of my friends and one
of my friends who is as liberal as they
come I've never said he trips up yeah
and he said to me it was this moment
like when you eat something that's
bitter at first and then you're like
what that tastes good ultimately yeah
and he said he's on to something and
that was when I knew that actually
resonated I didn't feel good at first I
mean I got it check because it was a
little dismissive and frankly the
African American community is still
enjoying the fact that we elected our
first African American president and
frankly so are a lot of non African
Americans right it was a big deal so
they felt like it was a shot at Obama
that that was the issue mm-hmm if you
had taken Obama out of the equation
having been the president it was a
totally reasonable
statement to say whoever the guy was
before he didn't meaningfully change
your life I am prepared to do what do
you have to lose so I think you just if
you took a bum out of it and the prat
associated with him being you know a
first I think it was totally logical
yeah ironically I think you can make a
great argument that the President
himself whether it's Obama or Trump or
anybody else shouldn't have that much
power over your life well that would be
my greater solution here that's my
attitude people say well you know I
wouldn't want to have lunch with Donald
Trump I said and you're not I wonder if
my president to do two things literally
I have sort of drawn it down to this
national security and Economic Security
I want the economy economy to be strong
globally I want that fine and then I
want to make sure that the homeland is
secure in the context of a global
contest so it's not just domestic but
you got to do some things on nationally
to protect your homeland those two
things I don't care what the president
thinks about much of anything because
he's a man just like I am than you are
so he'll have an opinion about X and
that's good for him there's Supreme
Court as Congress does all of that stuff
but I just want him to do two things
economic security and what I'll call
homeland but security national security
is it funny to you how everybody's sort
of flipped their opinions on almost
everything these days because as you're
saying that I'm thinking if we just go
back 20 minutes when we were talking
about daca it's like well suddenly
Democrats because they didn't like what
Trump was doing we're fighting for
states rights and it's like yeah I want
you guys to fight for states rights all
the time cuz then I'll start voting with
you again well look at the Obamacare the
new proposed Affordable Health Care Act
by the you know the idea is block grant
it to the states I thought that's what
we all want right it and I was surprised
to see some states actually no we don't
want it what do you mean you don't want
it the ability mr. M is governor to
manage and take care of your citizenry
with your dollars without the
intervention of some people in
Washington DC who know nothing about
what happens in Spokane Washington you
don't want and to me that's like the
most like perfect example of how screwed
up our system is that a governor who's
the executor of the state would be like
no no no the thing that I'm supposed to
do you do let's send it over there
way I'm free in the clear that's like
the worst that's why people hate
politicians it's why people hate the
media it's like holding I want I live in
California which they're probably gonna
execute my five-year-old for a little
free tonight a little bit a little
libertarian you know and it believe me
if they if they secede from the union
I'm really can I move in with put that
the Iowa that's what I do but but that
point basically of everything's being
flipped right now I like everyone's kind
of all over the place it's actually cool
I mean that's I know so many people are
depressed about it but what I've been
trying to say is there's opportunity
here it doesn't mean it's gonna be bad
it doesn't mean it's gonna be good but
let's get in there and fight for what
you believe even if you believe in the
stuff that I abhor right right but but
they're lazy I mean that you use the
right where people are lazy this is
actually fascinating to watch now I want
to separate earlier I said and you know
I'm nervous about where this is going
that's true I'm hopeful I'm not
necessarily optimistic and there's a
difference right yeah but I do enjoy
watching the process the sausage-making
I do like to see that ultimately you
know if you go back and look at some of
the at least the reports of the early
founding fathers it was ugly they hated
each other it was divided like nothing
you've ever seen and all of the what we
you know referred to as going on in
Congress right now hell it happened back
then too this might be the American
experience right and and you we just in
time what we do is we put a painting we
tell a story around it and it looks so
wonderful and dramatic but the reality
is it's ugly
you know operating in this sort of a
government this this model of governing
is is ugly yeah and it's got to be ugly
right I mean what's the option I mean I
think that's what people don't
understand is like if anything's gonna
work it kinda has to be ugly that I mean
the sausage factories are I think nobody
wants to see how it gets made I don't
like it no she liked it while I was
reading you have to dad know you've seen
it the continent son Boehner is now
talking about what happened you know
suddenly the man's Christmas brings it
up you know and the big idea that you
know some literally
got either pulled a gun or a knife on
him or something one of his fellow
members in Congress and it's just
fascinated literally he said and but
that's and that's within the party yeah
so the idea that somehow the tension is
is bad maybe not so much yeah it's also
funny because like you know you'll
always hear all the all these media
people and politicians be like house of
cards is the most realistic show ever
it's like well there's an awful lot of
murder and drug use and evil backdoor
deals and you're just you guys are all
kind of telling us that's right we're
all showing it to us all right well we
could go a rabbit hole on that one so
let's let's shift to your future because
you mentioned you mentioned earlier so
you are leaving the organization that
basically the end of next month right
and then where are you going what are
you doing going to run an organization
called the Society for Human Resource
Management sure and it's the world's
largest association dedicated to human
resources and so trade association for
the profession of human resources
professionals and you know so some have
said wow that's kind of out there well
no it isn't for for a couple of reasons
first of all I've been in hiring for the
last 17 half years if you ask 9 out of
10 college students why did you go to
college is to get a good job period
that's so it's a very natural kind of
thing there's no point of going if this
doesn't turn into some way to provide
the other thing though is it's a natural
sort of evolution in my career I now
understand higher ed actually I think I
have a really good understanding of all
of the education so P K through 16
mmm-hmm we've now got it connected
there's not an article that comes out
where employers say the system is not
giving me what I want the students who
graduating don't have the skills that we
need and so they're frustrated because
I'm paying taxes to pay for this system
education system and the what comes out
on the other hand the assembly line
model is Right really bad I paid for all
of this and at the end the car I don't
like it yeah so I think this gives me an
opportunity to take what I've done for
the last 7 and 1/2 years and now take
get industry bring the two together and
say let's figure out how to make the
system work we're spending a lot of
money as a country on education and to
what end so what are some of the ways
you could shift education I mean I think
the basic premises of get people
listen get people to really understand
what they believe in but is there
something that's like a little more
concrete that you're gonna go in and be
like guys let's this is what we got to
change yeah you know you know the
current administration is talking a lot
about apprenticeships for example the
endgame can't be everyone goes to
four-year college and I think we went
that way for too long yeah that didn't
work so the idea is to figure out
credentialing to figure out what are the
specific skills that one needs to go
into the 21st century economy industry
has to tell us that since they are
ultimately the consumer this education
product yeah and then we got to go back
and say okay now you've got to tweak
your system I know you all don't like
being vocations vocational schools and
you want to teach people how to think
and solve the world's problems
but the vast majority of the folks who
come through your system are doing what
they're trying to get a jobs yeah and so
that's what we're gonna do it concretely
bringing those education and industry
together and say let's figure this out
we've got to rethink and talk about
disruption I predict that higher
education in particular is going to be
disrupted in a way as a business as a
sector like nothing you've ever seen the
pieces are all there for that right now
because we see the schools that a lot of
the schools that have gone down the SJW
route are really struggling Mizzou is
majorly struggling enrollment we know
Evergreen State struggling I mean well
you have another problem America
Americans just had fewer babies the
reality is we we we've seen there are
fewer students graduating high school
this year than last year and the year
before so what we're seeing is a problem
you're just not going to have the same
number of bodies to come into that
traditional college environment that we
created with dorms and everything else
so now we've our non-traditional student
has to be our traditional student yeah
that's got to be a little ironic for you
in a way you come from the higher
anything you care so much about and yet
you can also acknowledge that a certain
amount of people just because of the
reality of economics don't necessarily
need all of that education that's you
know that's right and it's gonna be
lifelong you know it's the idea we came
out of the generation where you get your
education your masters your masters your
background whatever you get and then you
go into the workplace and do it for 30
years and you retire now and now because
the economy is changing so much every
five to seven years industries go away
that we were taught to participate in
they go away and so that's I'm so
excited about that finally you know sort
of related to that America is browning
and graying at once so underlying all of
this is we've got to figure out how to
get the system to appreciate a very
different America it's not black and
white anymore it's brown it's yellow
it's everything and how these workers as
they come out of college or whatever
their educational backgrounds are when
they come into the workplace how do we
grow our economy and we've got to use
people to do it right and that's what
I'm excited about Sherman higher
education and just trying to figure out
how to tie that all together yeah well I
gotta tell you that I thoroughly enjoyed
this I'm not surprised because as I said
I saw it once and I was like this guy is
gonna do it but I think the real beauty
of this is that you're not just saying
this stuff you're actually out there
doing it and I believe it that's right I
don't believe you know this isn't about
my desire to run for office or to get a
job I really believe this this is
something that it keeps me up at night
how can people like the two of us change
the narrative thank you thank you well I
feel like I got I gotta give you one
more here that'll alright what would you
say what would you say that well thank
you but what would you say then to the
to the people whether they're college
students right now or whether they're
you know middle-aged whatever it is that
want to get in the fight but are afraid
because of all the silencing factors you
know what I mean ya know two things
first of all you need courage you you've
got a intestinal courage you got just go
down and decide this is the pit this is
where I want to go and by the way that
means transferring schools if that means
changing the people you spend time
around because you know that can be
debilitating in some ways then do it I
mean it's just the only way to do it the
other thing is I would encourage all
Americans we've got to listen more the
most frustrating thing to me now is
we're so busy talking and frankly
talking over others that we just won't
pause and listen that's the beginning of
changing the narrative because as you're
listening you're going to one the other
person will respect you now because
you've listened to them and in the
process you actually might learn
something you might say you know the
world is a little different than
perceived it to be because I got it from
someone else's perspective that's the
beauty of diversity by the way mm-hmm
it's not just gender and race and
national origin it's diverse
perspectives how another person sees the
world if we can get those two things
down first of all listen
but then courage it takes a lot frankly
for me to be right here the best thing
in the world if I aspire to be a
congressman and a member of you know the
CBC and dah dah dah there's a narrative
that I'm supposed to follow and you've
got to decide that that that doesn't
matter what's more important is that the
American story a hundred years from now
is is a much better story because I was
here I loved it
that's a closing statement and for more
on Johnny you guys can follow them on
the Twitter machine it's at Johnny C
Taylor jr.
[Music]
you